Das Podcast-. Mir gegenüber sitzt wie immer in lauernder Stellung, hat sich angemessen verkleidet, Stefan Tietze. Und mir gegenüber sitzt in so einer Opfertierstellung, wo man angriffen werden will, der nicht zu mir guckt, der mit dem Rücken zu mir steht und irgendwie so Grasweide isst, flohen will. Falls ihr Stefan nur aus dem Podcast kennt, er ist ein Mensch, der aggressiv den Blickkontakt sucht. Also wirklich, wenn dir der Blickkontakt mal auf dem Boden fällt, nein, Stefan Tietze packt ihn und reißt ihn wieder in die Luft. Weisst du, woran das, glaube ich, liegt? Weil ich so gross bin und so leuchtturmartig quasi immer umgucke mich. Ich bin wie so ein, weiss nicht, wie so diese Murmeltiere, die so aufsteigen und dann gucken die herum. Und dann gehen die wieder ab. Aber ich bin ja generell in dieser lauer Stellung. Wurdest du gefragt, das Auge von Sauron zu spielen? Ja. Einfach der hohe Turm da oben? Ja, ich wurde gefragt und habe gesagt, hat aus Zeitgründen nicht hinge hingehauen, weil der ist ja oft zu sehen, ne? Ja, der fand ich oft zu sehen. Die hatte ich damals nicht wegen Abi. Aber sehr einsam, ne? Also konnte nie mit dem coolen Cast zusammenspielen, sondern immer nur alleine. Außer am Ende kurz mal. Außer am Ende, als er umgefallen ist, ungünstig. Vielen Dank an Banjo für dieses fantastische Intro mit einer Klassiker-Melodie, die alle das Podcast-Ufo-Hörer kennen sollten. Hallo, freut mich, schön, dass ihr da seid.
Aber was mich stört ist ein bisschen, also vielen Dank, mega Intro, aber dass man uns immer mit so diesen Comedy-Melodien versieht.
Mit diesem ... Was meinst du, woran das liegt, Stefan Dietze?
Fühlst du dich nicht ernst genug?
Nee, was ich immer gerne möchte, ist so ein ...
Warum, weil, und so sehen uns ja alle Hörer, so oder diese EDM-transartigen Dinger, die oft kommen, aber was nie kommt ist dieses so ein pathetisches, dieses pathetische Newsroom-artige Intro.
Ja, das stimmt.
Dieses, sie shapen unsere Welt, sie shapen die News, sie shapen wie wir denken und existieren.
Ich glaube, man verbindet uns nicht mit Fakten und Wahrheit und Neuigkeiten.
Wir erzählen Dinge, die vor 160 Jahren stattgefunden haben, falsch nach.
Ja, und Pathos. Pathos ist auch nicht bei uns irgendwie drin, aber ist okay.
Pathos, kann man bei dir vielleicht vermissen das Jahr über, aber nicht zu Halloween.
Du bist ein Halloween-Freak, du bist komplett angezogen, Kunstblut über das gesamte Gesicht geschmiert,
du hast einmal, du siehst ein riesiger Pappmaché-Haie, der dir in den Kopf beißt,
und das Blut läuft dir den ganzen Körper runter. Wie kamst du auf dieses Kostüm und warum trägst du es jetzt schon eine Woche nach Halloween noch? Es ist kein Pappmaché-Haie, es ist ein echter Hai. Oh, okay. Es ist auch kein Kunstblut, es ist mein Blut. Ich habe mal gesehen bei den Wrestlern, dass die, wenn die nämlich echt bluten wollen, weil Kunstblut sieht doch jeder. Jede Laie kann selbst erkennen, dass es Kunstblut ist. Und deswegen
schneidet man sich mit Rasierklingen
nur ganz bisschen,
ein kleines bisschen in die Kopfhaut rein.
Ein sehr empfindliches Stück Haut,
wo es dann blutet. Und das ist ein kleiner
Katzenhai, den habe ich
gefunden an der Ostsee.
Und er wollte mich nicht beißen.
Und dann habe ich den sehr lange auf meinem Kopf
gehalten, bis er irgendwann nicht mehr konnte. Ich habe den so unter Strom gesetzt mit einem Föhn, damit er irgendwann diese Konstruktivationen. Was für ein Aufwand. Ja, Halloween-Kostüme sind kein Bullshit. Ja, du setzt dir diesen Druck aber auch immer selber auf. Jedes Jahr versuchst du dich zu überbieten vom letzten Mal. Letztes Mal hast du dich ja komplett einmauern lassen, die Pyramide. Ja. Riesige Pyramide, irgendwie bist du zu Hause geblieben dann in deiner Pyramide, aber es war ein tolles Kostüm.
Ja, es war ein tolles Kostüm, aber halt sehr, sehr einsam.
Ja. Aber das ist halt eine Nachwägungsfrage.
Also für mich ist Halloween
an Platz eins aller kostümierten
Feste. Es ist mein Platz eins
der kostümierten Feste in Deutschland, von dem wir
ja sehr viele haben. Gerade hier in Köln hast du
noch mehr, das 11.11., das Karneval, das Halloween,
du bist ja quasi nur verkleidet. Konstant
eigentlich. Also es lohnt sich gar nicht, normale Kleidung zu kaufen, weil du eigentlich mehr verkleidet bist als nicht. Aber wann ist man eigentlich nicht verkleidet? Ja, oh, ganz, ganz tolle Frage. Ich bin heute auch schon losgezogen, habe aber nur Saurus bekommen. Also immer nur Saurus. Ich weiß auch gar nicht, warum man diese Option noch offen hält, warum man nicht einfach sagt, gib mir Süsses, sondern sagt, Süsses oder Saurus, ich kriege immer nur Saures, konstant. Und ich habe auch gelesen, dass jetzt viele Eltern haben sich beschwert, weil die erfahren haben, dass im letzten Jahr schon sehr viel Süsskern gegeben wurden. Und dann haben die Eltern das genommen und weggefordert geworfen. Was? Haben dann jetzt an die Türe gehangen, so bitte unseren Kindern nur Süsses geben oder saures, was aber gesund ist. Also zum Beispiel bei Süss oder saures dann halt entweder den roten Apfel oder den grünen Apfel. Oh nein, oh come on. Das ist das Schlimmste, was man seinen Kindern antun kann, ist so dieses, wir feiern ja gesundes Halloween. Also nein, lass dir doch einen Tag mal im Jahr Kind sein. Ich denke mir, das ist halt wie The Purge, weil das ist doch voll okay, an diesem einen Tag sich bis in die Ohnmächtigkeit zu fressen, dann zu kotzen. Das ist doch genau das, was man braucht. Dass man das ganze Jahr diese Frit- oder diese Pets-Spender nicht mehr sehen kann. Da hat man keinen Bock mehr drauf.
Ja, ich kann Kamelle den Rest des Jahres nicht sehen. An dem einen Tag im Jahr gerne, Herr damit. Schatz, möchtest du gerne eine Kamelle haben? Oh, ne, weißt du, ich habe ja vor letztem Monat habe ich mir schon richtig die Kamelle gegeben und dann habe ich jetzt keinen Hunger mehr. Keinen Hunger mehr. So funktioniert das und deswegen natürlich die Kamelle-Industrie auch stark im Verzweifeln. Ja, so sehr im Verzweifeln, dass sie jetzt anfangen, von Wägen, mit denen sie durch die Innenstadt fahren, auf Leute zu werfen. Kostenpflichtig die Drops runterzuwerfen. Ja, auf Leute zu bewerfen. Da müsst ihr aufpassen. Da müsst ihr aufpassen. Also deswegen immer einen Regenschirm mitnehmen. Ich habe damals als Kind die Strategie verfolgt,
gar nicht erst versuchen, die Sachen
aus der Luft zu fangen, weil du bist ja klein als Kind.
Ich war immer auf dem Boden unterwegs.
Ich war einer dieser Goldlum-Kinder,
die dann zwischen den Füssen der anderen Kinder rumgeschlichen
sind und die Sachen vom Boden genommen haben, wo die anderen
schon zweimal draufgestiegen sind. Seitdem ich
aber Lion King gesehen habe, hätte ich
davon abgeraten.
Weil das ist nämlich genau das, du bist wie der kleine Simba, der durch die Gnu-Herde rumwatscht. Das ist die Message von Lion King gesehen habe, hätte ich dir davon abgeraten. Weil das ist genau das, du bist wie der kleine Simba, der durch die Gnu-Herde rumwatscht.
Das ist die Message von Lion King?
Mhm, dass man nicht an Karneval unter den Trampelnden Menschen, ja, du hast dich auch
an den Trampelnden Menschen unten auf den Knien.
König der Löwen ist karnevalskritisch.
Ja.
Das ist eine karnevalskritische Gesellschaftskritik. Das ist eine karnevalskritische Gesellschaftskarakterkritik. Krass. Das ist verrückt. Das ist immer an mir vorbeigegangen. Aber dass du gerade meintest, dass du als Kind folgende Strategie verfolgt hast. Ich habe als Kind glaube ich nie eine Strategie verfolgt. Habe ich ein bisschen nachgedacht. Einfach impulsiv Hände in die Höhe gemacht. Und ich behaupte auch, jedes gesunde Kind, No Front, sollte keine Strategie verfolgen. Nein? Sondern einfach nur machen, was es denkt, was es machen soll. Ich glaube, glaubst du nicht gerade, Kinder sind extrem strategisch begabt, weil sie müssen ja konstant ihre Eltern manipulieren? Mit diesem klassischen, ich weiß noch, wie ich damals von Lego-Technik gab es diese Star-Wars-Reihe mit diesen programmierbaren Computern drin. Da gab es den AT-80 und den R2-D2. Und da konnte man so dumme Sachen programmieren wie, fahr drei Sekunden nach vorne, dann dreh dich. Und ich habe gesagt, ja, ich möchte ja was mit Computern machen und programmieren lernen. Deswegen brauche ich das eigentlich für die Schule, um das zu lernen und habe versucht, damit durchzukommen. Und ich glaube schon, dass Kinder sehr gut darin sind,
sich einfach Nonsens auszudenken, um das irgendwie als,
ich brauche den Laptop ja für die Schule,
ich brauche TikTok für die Schule und sowas, um da durchzukommen.
Aber musstest du ihn auch wieder abgeben,
als du dann bei der Frank-Elster-Masterclass angenommen wurdest?
Als meine Eltern langsam die Lunte gerochen haben und gesagt haben,
Moment mal, Lunte, du riechst nach Lunte.
Hat schon wieder jemand, gibt es eigentlich Duftkerzen, die nach Lunte riechen? Ja, Lunte, die verkaufen wir. Die sehen nämlich genauso aus wie alle anderen Designer, die seien die Luftduftkerzen mit so einer coolen Schrift, so amerikanische Ölfelsche, aber da steht bei uns einfach nur Lunte. Wollen Sie die Lunte oder den Braten riechen? Das sind so die beiden Geschmacksrichtungen, die man sich holen kann. Das ist doch meine, weil momentan hat jeder Eistee, jeder hat Eistee, du willst ja auch an den Markt. Ich glaube, der nächste Shit sind Duftkerzen. Alle Promis, alle Podcasts bringen Duftkerzen raus. Finde ich sehr gut. Lunte, Braten finde ich aber auch nicht schlecht. Die Leute wollen wieder was riechen. Hast du die Lunte schon gerochen? Ja, habe ich auch bei mir zu Hause. Die Leute wollen wieder was erleben. Das finde ich ganz gut. Ja, vielleicht sind wir da, sollen wir da einen Trend starten? Wir können die Kerze benennen, zum Beispiel, from the top of my head, das Podcast-Urfe. Ja, okay. Ja, können wir mal überlegen, ob wir das noch raushauen. Wie steigt man denn jetzt in die Duftkerzenindustrie ein? Wie startet man überhaupt irgendwas? How do I start the process? Also entweder du schaust, dass du dir eine Duftkerzenfabrik vererben lässt. Das ist sehr einfach. Also du schaust dir um, wo in Deutschland sind Duftkerzenfabriken, stellst dich da vor die Tür und sagt, ich hätte Zeit, ich hätte Erbgut vorhanden, ich bin Erbgut. Und dann musst du natürlich überlegen. Generell immer ein guter Gespräch starten. Ich bin Erbgut. Außer jetzt beim Flirten würde ich es nicht sofort sagen. Und das ist dann das Problem, aber ansonsten, es gibt bestimmt, ich glaube ja, viele Leute haben keinen Bock auf das, was sie machen. Die haben von den Eltern vielleicht die Duftkerzenmanufaktur geerbt. Und die, wenn du denen sagst, für 10.000 Euro, und die sagen, ja sofort, ja sofort, die wollen raus. Stehst du gerade den grossen Swapperoo vor eigentlich? Ja, der grosse Swapperoo, die Leute wollen raus und einfach nochmal neu aushöhlen, nochmal von vorn anfangen. Aber ich glaube, erstmal musst du per Handarbeit anfangen und das selber zusammenrühren zu Hause mit allen Töpfen. Nimm alle Töpfe, die wir haben. Alles, was du an Lavendeltöpfen in die Hände bekommst und Wachs. Ja, und dann alles Lundengeruch musst du halt irgendwie versuchen, synthetisch herzustellen, was schwierig wird. Nee, gar nicht. Dein alter R2D2. Ja, dann der MacBook, den ich damals für die Hausaufgaben bekommen habe. Vielleicht sowas wie so Wunderkerzen, so wie das riecht, so dieses verschmorte Silvestergeruchfeeling, glaube ich. Ich glaube, dafür reicht mein Topf. Wenn du sagst, verschmort, ich glaube, da reicht einfach, wie mein Topf immer schmeckt, weil viel Unglück drin passiert ist. Ja, finde ich nicht so schlecht Können wir einfach mal machen. Dann füllen wir das ab in den Gläser und den Docht nicht vergessen. Ich würde sogar den Doppeldocht etablieren. Das fand ich immer das allercoolste, die Kerzen, die gesagt haben, ein Docht. Ja, so acht. Er hat gesagt, ich bin besser als andere Kerzen. Wo ich mir schon damals dachte, was nimmst du dir eigentlich raus? Kerze. Fünfdochtige Kerze, du denkst,
du bist was Besseres, vor allem die dann teilweise auch die Flammen der Dochte
sich verbündet haben, zusammengetan
haben und von den fünf Dochten
haben drei einfach eigene Sache gemacht
und sich verbündet und die beiden
außen haben zugeschaut. Ich denke mir, das sind Dramen,
die sich da abspielen in diesem Docht
Bereich, da wo irgendwie
Game of Docht, dass sich die alle zusammentun. Game of Docht und Game of Kerzenfabrik, also auch die Leute, die dann sagen, fuck, jetzt hatten die das zuerst, jetzt haben die das umgesetzt mit dem Doppeldocht. Das ist auch ein Wettrüsten, glaube ich, wo man irgendwo den verpasst hat, abzubiegen. Zwei Dochte, dann kamen drei Dochte raus, dann vier Dochte und immer mehr und die Leute wussten gar nicht mehr, was sie überhaupt noch machen sollen.
Ja, und dann finde ich es fast sympathischer, einfach die Kerzenfabrik abzustoßen für 10.000 Euro. Ich glaube, das ist dann viel sympathischer als das über-ehrgeizige, wir haben einen Doppeldocht und alle anderen Firmen so. Also falls ihr eine Duftkerzenfabrik braucht, wir hätten eine, falls ihr die abnehmen wollt, wir haben kein Interesse mehr dran. Aber ich habe mir erzählt, da wo ich häufig gearbeitet habe, bei meiner Mom in der Firma, wo ich manchmal im Labor war und sowas, habe ich in Sommerferien und so gearbeitet. Und genau gegenüber war eine Aroma-Firma, Givaudin, eine Schweizer Firma, die Führenden Aromen herstellen. Und da rocht immer das ganze Industriegebiet in Dortmund, rocht wirklich nach dem, was sie da gerade hergestellt haben. Das konnten die sich nicht aussuchen, das konnten sich alle anderen nicht aussuchen, aber alle hatten dieses Silent Agreement, dass man damit klarkommen musste, dass die gerade irgendwie, keine Ahnung, Spekulatius-Time haben. Aber natürlich auch ein leichtes Spiel für alle Wirtschaftsspione, die wirklich da einfach mal einmal in der Woche hingehen und schnüffeln und sagen, Moment mal, die machen jetzt wieder Spekulatius. Ich rieche Spekulatius, ich rieche Zimt, ich rieche weisser Pfeffer, ich rieche Paprika. Gib das weiter in die Zentrale. Ja, ich rieche Hotdog und der Kollege so, sorry. Die 80s Comedy Szene geworden. Der Pförtner, schön mit dem Vierer Hotdog. Sorry. Mit dem Vierer Hotdog einmal davor. Aber das stimmt schon, du kannst eigentlich da nicht verschleiern, was du herstellst. Und du kannst den Leuten auch sagen, ja, kommt rein, es ist eh nicht geheim, was wir herstellen. Ja, oder die haben am Schornstein oben so einen Filter dran, der aber gleichzeitig den Rauch von was anderem ausstrahlt, was die vor 30 Jahren gemacht haben. Ach, die machen Spekulatius, ja. Einfach so neben dem Schornstein so eine riesige Deo-Flasche aktiviert, wo dann einfach die Praktikantin hochklettern muss und einmal so mit ganzer Kraft auf den Drucker springt und dann einfach der komplette Spekulatiusgeruch wird übertüncht mit Deo. Kann auch sein. Ich fand es immer sehr angenehm. Ja, kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Fenster auf und es rocht direkt nach. Es war auch nicht wie Fenster aufmachen, es rocht wie einen Ofen aufmachen und man weiß nicht, was passiert. Ich glaube, das ist auch wichtig. Leute, die eine Wohnung oder Haus kaufen, denken immer an Aussicht und Verkehrsanbindung. Die denken selten an Geruch, wo man wirklich so was sind die deutschen Geruchshotspots, weil wenn du irgendwie, keine Ahnung, neben einer Lebkuchenfabrik lebst, ist das doch das beste Leben. Du einfach machst das Fenster auf, ziehst einmal diesen Geruch ein. Ja, du bist ja generell Geruchskonisseur, ich ja auch. Du hast aber ja auch die Erfahrung gemacht mit deiner Katze, deines Mitbewohner, die bei dir Ränge pickelt ins Zimmer. Und du hast ja auch schon vor einigen Folgen gesagt, dass du glaubst, dass es der aggressivste Sinn ist, der dich am meisten wach hält. Deswegen glaube ich auch, ich glaube sehr an Gerüche und an die Macht des Geruchs. Ich glaube, man muss sich daran sehr, man muss sich darauf achten. Haben uns auch Leute geschrieben, die sich auskennen mit dem Gehirn und die haben gesagt, ja, das ist tatsächlich so, dass der, ich fasse das jetzt mal für Laien zusammen, damit... Nee, nee, nee, nee. Mach mal richtig für... Ich möchte das einfach mal ein bisschen runterbrechen. Und zwar hieß es so in etwa, ich vereinfache es jetzt stark, dass die Nase mehr oder weniger direkt ans Gehirn angeschlossen ist. Angeschlossen. Wohingegen die anderen Sinne noch durch so einen Filterteil durchlaufen. Aber direkt von der Nase mit HDMI direkt ins Hirn. Mit Glasfaser straight rein und halt dann, ich versuche jetzt alle Fachbegriffe zu vermeiden gerade, und der Teil des Gehirns, der so rausfiltert, da geht die Nase nicht durch. Das heißt, wenn du Dinge siehst oder hörst, da filtert das Gehirn schon raus. Wenn du siehst, das Augenlied meinst du, das ist der Filter. Ja, genau, zum Beispiel kennt man ja auch dann so Sachen wie der Gorilla, den man nicht sieht, weil man abgelenkt ist, weil das halt einfach rausgefiltert wird. Und da habe ich mir gedacht, ob das stimmt, weiß ich nicht. Ein Gegenbeispiel. Man riecht seine eigene Wohnung nicht. Immer wenn du bei jemandem anders zu Besuch bist, hat die Wohnung und das Haus einen bestimmten Geruch, bei dir zu Hause aber nicht. Du riechst auch deinen eigenen Körpergeruch. Das stimmt nicht. Haha, halten Sie, bleiben Sie stehen, Mann mit den vielen Thesen. Jetzt hast du mich erwischt, in flagranti erwischt. Mann mit den vielen Thesen, bleiben Sie genau da stehen. Wobei, wenn du mal so tief an deinem Kissen riechst, riechst du doch deinen Körpergeruch. Riech mal, nimm mal einen tiefen... Ja, aber das ist dein Körpergeruch? Nee, das ist dein... Was soll das denn sonst sein? Nee, halt tote Milben gepaart mit toten Haaren, gepaart mit viel Speichel. Körpergeruch. Deinen Speichel riechst du schon oder so. Ja, aber deine Bohnen riechst du ja auch, wenn du reingehst, nach langer Zeit. Ja, nach langer Zeit, genau. Nach langer Zeit, aha, aha, I rest my case.
Schmich nicht, das ist auch mein Podcast.
Nee, aber ich habe die Thesen gerade.
Nee, wenn jetzt anfangen Leute zu schn im Pod. Hey, nein, das lassen wir sagen, das kommt nicht mehr vor.
Das ist ein big no-go.
Nach 280 Folgen habe ich endlich entdeckt,
dass ich Stefan einfach pssst, einfach Ruhe jetzt bitte.
Also, und zwar möchte ich sagen, dass genau das beweist, dass auch der Geruchssinn rausfiltert, weil man seine eigene Wohnung nicht riecht. Und Hundebesitzer riechen auch ihren Hund nicht, habe ich gehört. Weil jeder Mensch, der neben dem Hund steht und sich denkt, äh, sorry? Ja. Können wir vielleicht darüber reden, dass dieser Hund einfach abgrundtief stinkt? Das ist das Schlimmste gewesen. Furchtbar. Und du denkst dir, der Besitzer riecht es sehr. Ja, wir hatten irgendwie eine Produktionsleiterin oder sowas bei How to Sell Drugs, die den stinkendsten Hund der ganzen Welt. Und das war furchtbar. Und ich bin morgens ins Bürogebäude gegangen und habe gesagt, oh Gott, ist das der schon wieder hier, der Hund, weil er durch das ganze Gebäude gerochen hat. Und der war süss und nett und lieb, aber wir haben uns gut verstanden, eine gute Ebene, aber er hat gestunken. Und auf dem Abschlussfest hat sie dann zu mir gesagt, ach übrigens, ich habe herausgefunden, warum er so gestunken hat. Und dann lustigerweise musste ich den noch einmal mit so einem Schampoo, mit so einem speziellen Schampoo eincremen und dann war der wieder fit. Und ich so, willst du mich eigentlich verarschen? Und dann hat sie gesagt, ja, ich habe es vorher nicht hingegeben, ich hätte keine Zeit dafür, diesen Hund zum Tierarzt zu bringen, weil so viel Stress war. Naja, ich war, ich stinke sauer darüber. Ja, eigentlich sollte man an dem Tag Stopp, heute wird keine Sekunde gedreht. Nee. Wir setzen uns jetzt alle mal zusammen und lösen mal dieses eine Problem hier. Wir lösen the dog in the room, lösen wir jetzt mal. Und wenn es das nicht gelöst ist, drehen wir nicht weiter. Nein, wir drehen nicht. Dann soll Netflix gucken, wie sie ihre Serie kriegt. Es wird langfristig das bessere Investment sein, diesen Hund erst mal zum Normalriechen zu bringen. Was aber einerseits heißt, dass sie es auch gerochen hat oder durch Feedback erfahren hat, aber ich glaube, Hundebesitzer riechen ihren Hund nicht, was auch bedeutet, man die Nase filtert. Aber ich denke, die Nase ist langsamer. Glaube ich einfach nur. Keine Ahnung. Die langsamer. Jetzt hast du mich erwischt. Die braucht länger. Sind Sie sicher, dass Sie die These aufstellen wollen? Bei einer einzigen Nachfrage geht sie kaputt und du hast auf Okay gedrückt, nicht auf Abbrechen. Nee, ich habe auf Okay gedrückt. Ich habe mich verklickt. Trotzdem aufstellen. Ja, das bräuchte man täglich mal so ein großes. Das sind sehr viele so Fenster, die einen fragen. Ja, so Pop-Ups. Willst du es wirklich? Nee, komm, ach, du hast doch Besseres zu tun. Stinkt dein Hund? Probier das erst mal aus, ob das vielleicht ist. Naja, naja, naja. Jedenfalls habe ich neulich ein Wein-Seminar verschenkt und war auch dann Teil dieses Abends.
Und dann hast du mir erzählt, dass du ja parallel auch immer in Moin mal darüber gesprochen hattest wohl, dass du über Gerüche gesprochen hast, über so eine Box, die man kaufen kann, wo man Gerüche erschnüffeln kann. Genau, so normierte, genormte Gerüche, so fünfzig kleine Fläschchen mit Geruchseszenzen, so dass wenn Weinkenner miteinander reden, sie sozusagen diese Sprache an Gerüchen haben und wissen, wovon sie reden, wenn sie sagen rosig, vanillig, bla bla.
Das finde ich nämlich ganz toll, weil bei diesem Weinseminar war vor allem die ganze Zeit halt, hat man über Gerüche gesprochen und so und sich verständigt.
Was ja nur, es klingt immer von außen hin total so hochgestochen und quatschig,
meint aber nur, man muss ja irgendwie ein Vokabular finden, um zu besprechen,
was eigentlich sehr subjektiv ist.
Um das irgendwie zu objektivieren
und darüber reden zu können, um
zu verhindern, dass man was bestellt, was man nicht mag.
So, also eigentlich,
und das Vokabular dafür ist halt ein bisschen seltsam.
Und manchmal, da stand
bei einem Wein dabei, dass es nach Visalis
riecht.
Wo man dann denkt, ach komm, kann man nicht
Vielen Dank. Und das Vokabular dafür ist halt ein bisschen seltsam. Und manchmal, da stand bei einem Wein dabei, dass es nach Visalis riecht, wo man dann denkt, ach komm, kann man nicht zumindest irgendwie dann uns auf fünf Obstsorten einigen, die wir nehmen. Und Visalis ist vielleicht sehr speziell, aber man checkt es irgendwie, weil es so ein spitzer Geschmackgeruch ist. Aber naja, und deswegen finde ich es sehr spannend spannend, mal irgendwie diese Essenzen an sich zu riechen. Ja, es ist total spannend und also vor allem, was es da auch für verschiedene Sachen gibt, ist ja auch unfassbar, wonach Wein alles schmecken kann. Mich interessieren allerdings noch mehr die sogenannten Fehlgerüche. Die Gerüche, die ein Wein gerade nicht haben soll, weil der Winzer muss ja auch rausschmecken können, oh, da ist was falsch gelaufen. Und unter diesen Fehl, da gibt es verschiedene Sachen, ganz explizit, wie nach die Falschgeläte. Verkorkt ja auf jeden Fall. Verkorkt, Essig irgendwie zu sauer, schimmlig, das Weinfass war schimmlig. Und dann gibt es aber noch den Fehlgeruch Pferd. Also es kann sein, dass bei der Weinproduktion irgendwas falsch läuft,
irgendwie dann die Weintraube wird falsch gepflückt oder so,
oder die wird gegen den Uhrzeigersinn abgedreht. Und plötzlich, zack, die gesamte Weinerde komplett verpferdet.
Und das kannst du ja wegkippen.
Das kannst du dann schön irgendwie an Malotze in Sangria-Eimer füllen,
aber nicht mehr verkaufen.
Und deswegen muss jeder Winzer diesen Geschmack von Pferd haben, um das rauszuschmecken. Und ich bin kurz davor, mir diese Fehlgeruchspalette zu bestellen, weil ich einfach das so spannend finde, dass von allen Tieren der Welt gerade das Pferd auftaucht bei den Fehlern, wie es nicht riechen soll.
Und mich fasziniert auch der Entstehungsprozess.
Wir haben jetzt gerade schon gerätselt, wie machen wir das Geruchlunte.
Das ist natürlich schwierig, aber ich stelle mir da einfach vor.
Große Geruchsfolge heute.
Ja, große Geruchsfolge.
Ich stelle mir auch vor, dass sie einfach so bei der Pferde-Geruchsmanufaktur so einen riesigen Mixer haben,
wo die einfach so ein Pferd aus so einem Fließband fällt, so ein Pferd einfach in diesen Mixer. Dırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırırferd gerochen hat, weil Givaudin hat wohl angefangen, ein bisschen mit Pferd zu experimentieren. Ich glaube nämlich, das sind diese Essenzen.
Ich glaube, diese Firma macht diese Essenzen, von denen du gerade sprichst.
Oh, das kann gut sein.
Und wir haben ja American Bullshit gesehen oder American Hustle, wie es im Original heisst,
wo Jennifer Lawrence' Figur ja immer sagt.
Bitte was?
Jedes...
Nee, nee, ich will kurz zurückspulen.
Sorry.
Der Film, der im Deutschen American Bullshit heisst, heisst im Original American Hustle.
Der heisst im Deutschen American Bullshit? Wahrscheinlich, weil man dachte, dass das deutsche Publikum nicht weiss, was Hustle bedeutet. Das stimmt. Ja. Aber es ist ja auch so ein bisschen onomatopoetisch Hustle. Ja, es ist ja ein bisschen Hustle. Hustle ist ein fantastisches Wort. Oh, ich Hustle hier rum. Ja, ja. Könnte auch locker ein deutsches Wort werden. H-A-S-S-E-L,, hassel. Sprecht mal mit euren Großeltern, die jetzt nicht Englisch sprechen, und sagt mal, ich habe gestern auch wieder so rumgehasselt damit, irgendwie. Sagt das mal im Satz, die verstehen das alle. Das kann sein, dass es schon so klingt. Wenn du hingegen sagst, das war so ein Bullshit, was da im Fernsehen läuft, weiss ich nicht, ob die das genau wissen. Ja, wenn du sagst, um mir das Auto zu leisten, muss ich jetzt echt hasseln. Ich weiß nicht, ob Oma das versteht. Macht mal die Podcast-Ufo-Hausaufgabe, redet mal mit euren Eltern. Mit den Leuten, die nicht Englisch sprechen können. Genau, und benutzt mal das Wort hasseln und versucht es so deutsch auszusprechen, wie es geht. Also wirklich zu hasseln. Boah, ey, ich bin die ganze Woche wieder am hasseln nur. Und dann guckt mal, ob das ankommt oder nicht. Und versucht aber auch, also ihr müsst verschiedene, eigentlich müsst ihr auch einmal neutral das sagen, weil ich habe gerade das Gefühl gehabt, dass ich so ein bisschen suggestiv gearbeitet habe, wenn ich sage, die ganze Woche durchgehasselt schon wieder. Stimmt schon, ja, egal welches Wort ihr benutzt. Ich glaube, ihr müsst einfach so sehr neutral, so biometrisches Foto mässig neutral gucken, nicht lachen, nicht irgendwie die Augen zusammenkneifen oder sowas und sagen, gestern die ganze Woche habe ich schon wieder durchgehasselt. Und ich glaube, und dann wird es vielleicht schwieriger, aber könnt ihr euch ja absprechen mit meinen Freunden, dass die einen das machen, die anderen das machen. Vielleicht liegt das daran. Macht eine Kontrollgruppe in einem Freundeskreis, die hilft. Vielleicht macht deswegen niemand unsere Hausaufgaben, weil wir immer Einschränkungen eintreten. Oder weil die Leute sagen, eure scheiß Hausaufgaben haben mein gesamtes Sozialleben ruiniert, meine Eltern reden nicht mit mir, meine Oma ruft nicht mehr an. Das ist nicht der Grund. Der Grund ist, weil es so viele Variablen gibt, weil ihr Aufgabe 1a, 1b, 2a bis d und Aufgabe 4 machen sollt. Drei hatten wir erst gesagt, müsst ihr aber jetzt doch nicht machen. Und am Ende haben alle die Hausaufgabe nicht, weil es unklar war. Weil es C gar nicht gab, nur A und B und die nicht wussten, was man machen soll. Und da sagt Jennifer Lawrence Figur, sagt, dass in jedem guten Geruch auch ein bisschen was Ekelhaftes ist. Das ist ja natürlich eine Metapher für den gesamten Film. Es muss immer was Ekelhaftes dabei sein, um so eine gewisse Faszination zu haben. In jedem Geruch ist auch was Ekelhaftes. Und ich glaube, da ist was dran. Und ich glaube, wenn du so diesen Geruch hast, wo du weißt, das ist abstoßen, Pferd, und das dann mal in so einen Cocktail tust, so einen Tropfen Pferd in einen Cocktail oder in dein Essen oder so, so einen Hauch von, na, weil das ist ja auch so, ich glaube, Ekel und Genuss ist immer nah beieinander. Denk an Schimmelkäse,
denk an irgendwie diese Papageien, denen man den
Schnabel abbeisst oder was auch immer.
Tauben.
Quatsch.
Und ich glaube, das passt zusammen. Und wenn ich diesen Pferdegeruch
mal habe, dann würde ich mal auch fragen,
wenn Leute dran riechen lassen,
ohne zu sagen, wonach riecht das?
Was wir machen, ist nämlich, also, weil
jetzt habe ich nämlich gerade auch noch ein Doku darüber geguckt, über Sommeliers, weil es ist spannend, da haben wir ganz so ein Doku entdeckt. So, und jetzt Es ist ein, das die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die, die,? Was wir machen, ist nämlich, also, weil jetzt habe ich nämlich gerade auch noch ein Doku darüber geguckt, über Sommeliers, weil es spannend ist, da haben wir eine ganz schöne Doku entdeckt. So, und jetzt Weinphase beginnt, merkt ihr. Oh, die nächste Weinphase, die Sommeliers. Diese unangenehme Folgen folgen jetzt, wo ich die ganze Zeit betrunken bin, wollen wir nicht, aber können wir jetzt auch nicht verhindern. Ja. Grosse Sommelier-Doku, Somm heisst die Somm, gibt es da mittlerweile drei Teile, ich habe
jetzt nur einen Teil einzig, lustigerweise genau bis wir gerade angefangen haben aufzunehmen. Somm, Somm. Und da geht es um vier Leute, die sich vorbereiten auf die Master Sommelier-Examen. Spannend. Richtig geil und da geht es vor allem darum, dass sie lernen müssen, blind Weine zu verkosten. Also du musst wirklich, die verkosten blind drei Weissweine und drei Rotweine und müssen eigentlich den Wein bestimmen, sagen, woher der kommt. Nord, keine Ahnung, Nordburgund zum Beispiel und so, müssen es genau dann reinbauen, Napa Valley, Kalifornien, daher kommt es. Also die müssen sehr, sehr genau diese Weine bestimmen. Das geht tatsächlich. Und das kriegen die hin und es ist total geil. Und ich würde ja gerne mal, weil da bin ich noch nicht, ich würde mit dir gerne erstmal bei normalen Gerüchen anfangen. Dass wir bei diesen Standardgerüchen und bei diesen Fehlgerüchen, dass du mir blind irgendwie fünf, sechs Gerüche gibst und ich muss dir sagen, das ist jetzt Brombeere, das ist jetzt Fisalis, weil ich glaube auch nicht, dass das so einfach ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Nee, überhaupt nicht.
Vor allem das ist ja dann auch die Frage, ob Geruch und Geschmack so ähnlich ist oder ob du es dann auch schmecken musst.
Weil das ist ja so ein Fläschchen.
Ich glaube schon, dass die Idee ist, dass man es schmeckt, sich so irgendwie auf die Zunge träufelt oder auf ein Brot schmiert.
Geschmack ist ja 85 Prozent Geruch, habe ich heute auch gelernt.
Was sind die restlichen 15 Prozent? Geschmack. Also der Rest ist dann Zungenalarm, oder was? Ja, Speichelbildungs-Shit. Zungenalarm, ich glaube Zungenalarm, so süss, sauer, bitter, was die Zunge halt wahrnehmen kann. Aber der Rest ist Geruch. Almi-Sauer, vielleicht habe ich einen Zahlenreher drin, bin mir nicht sicher. Generell weiß man ja, wenn man Dokus guckt danach, denkt man, man hat alles verstanden, dann kommt eine Rückfrage, man denkt, ja, ich habe nichts.
Ich habe das Gefühl, mein Geschmackssinn ist komplett weg. Ich glaube, diese Mr. Max fünf Liter Flaschen haben mir einfach die letzten bisschen Geschmacksnerven weggeätzt, die ich noch hatte, weil ich habe mittlerweile auch kein Bedürfnis mehr nach gutem Essen. Ich denke mir oft im Supermarkt so, oh geil, heute mache ich mir mal so ein Sandwich. So richtig schön, irgendwie mit getoastetem Brot und irgendwie so mit frischen Tomaten und Salat drauf und vielleicht mal so irgendwas anbraten, die Tomaten dann vielleicht nochmal so anbraten, irgendwie was Tolles drauf und so. Und dann nehme ich mir, nee, ich hätte viel lieber diese Plastiktüten-Sandwiches, diese Plastikpackung-Sandwiches, die würden mir jetzt besser schmecken. Nee. Und ich denke mir, das kann doch nicht sein, dass ich das wirklich vorziehe. Ich glaube, bei mir ist mittlerweile der Geschmack so falsch rum gepolt, dass es einfach auch alles verloren ist. Mein Geschmackssinn ist so Crab und Trash gewohnt, dass es gar nicht mehr anders kann, als das zu verlangen. Wahnsinn. Weil das habe ich zum Beispiel nicht, bei mir ist es dann einfach, ich esse
aus Faulheit, also ich würde
auch wahrscheinlich am Ende zum gleichen Ergebnis kommen
und wie du einfach das fertige Sandwich
kaufen, aber aus anderen Gründen,
also mein Genese wäre, ah nee,
kein Bock, jetzt Tomaten anzubraten,
geht das überhaupt, darf man das,
ist das Ding in den 101 der
Küche überhaupt erlaubt,
nee, komm, machen wir es so, und dann würde ich wahrscheinlich auch das Sandwich kaufen. Aber bei mir, keine Ahnung, ich glaube, ich bilde mir eine, aber das ist auch so ein Ding, aber ich bilde mir eine, ich kann gut riechen und schmecken, habe auch eine große Nase. Das muss ja für irgendwas gut sein. Ja, können Hunde so gut riechen, weil sie so eine große Schnauze haben. Riesige Schnauze haben. Also ist es wirklich so?
Größere Nasen können besser riechen, oder ist das Quatschalberne Vorurteile?
Nee, ich glaube das schon.
Weil so ein Hund kann ja, also Eulen
haben grosse Augen und können gut sehen.
Hunde haben grosse Nasen und können gut riechen.
Ist die Welt einfacher,
als wir denken, vielleicht?
Grosse Elefanten haben riesengroße
Ohren, können aber aber auch einen grossen Rüssel, also die können viel gut einfach, die sind generell sehr gross. Giraffen haben lange Beine, aber können nicht gut rennen. Das glaube ich nicht. Also, nee, jetzt ist es albern. Nee, oder? Also, nee, generell grosse Tiere sind ja dann generell besser in allem. Das ist die These, die wir gerade aufstellen. Je grösser das Tier, desto ist also es ist auch irgendwann unerträglich laut für die, unerträglich hell. Aber haben Elefanten größere Augen als Eulen? Ich glaube schon, ja. Ich weiß auch nicht, wie du darauf kommst, dass Eulen große Augen haben. Verhältnismäßig schon. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass wir kleinere haben als Eulen. Doch, klar. Eulen? Die Augen sind noch so groß, dass sie den Kopf drehen müssen.
Zeig mal mit deinen Händen an,
wie groß du glaubst sind Eulenaugen.
So groß ist dein Auge auch.
Ja, du bist weit weg. Das ist völlig
albern. Flonti zeigt wie so eine
faustgroße
Auge. Wie so ein Tischtennisball. Das glaubst du
auch selber nicht. Ja, die Tischtennisball hast du auch im Kopf.
Zwei.
Und im Herzen.
Das stimmt, ja. Du liebst Tischtennis.
Aber, also das weiss ich,
Das war's für heute. Jetzt steht das Ballast ja auch im Kopf. Zwei. Und im Herzen. Das stimmt, ja. Du liebst Hirschlein es. Aber, also das weiss ich, das ist jetzt aber echt ein guter Punkt eigentlich, ne, aber vor allem Ohren ist, ich glaube bei Ohren kann man das nicht sagen, je grösser die Ohren, weil zum Beispiel, was ich auch gar nicht verstehe, so Hasen oder so, die haben grosse Ohren, aber die hängen so runter. Was soll denn das? Nee, aber, was ist denn da los? Ja, das verstehe ich auch nicht. Die können ja aufstellen. Nee, können sie nicht. Ist das sowas wie wir die Augen zumachen können? Dass sie die Ohren darunter klappen? Ja, weil guck mal, wenn du sehr gut hörst, ist das ja eine unenträgliche Vorstellung. Ich möchte kein Auge zumachen, wenn ich so gut hören könnte wie Hasen. Dann müsst ihr die ganze Zeit, ach, könnt ihr mal da hinten die Klappe halten, da drüben in Köln-Wesseling. Ja, ich glaube, jetzt sind wir
am Hasen-Kaninchen
an der Front. Ich glaube, Hasen
können ihre Löffel aufstellen.
Aber Kaninchen, die haben einfach nur
die Schlappnummern da.
Und das verstehe ich gar nichts, weil entweder
hören die gar nichts, aber ich bin hier so eingeklemmt
zwischen zwei Tischen.
Ich fühle mich wie so eine Walnuss in so einer Zange,
die jede Sekunde
beknackt einfach. Ich bin wirklich
Vielen Dank. die ja gar nichts, aber ich bin hier so eingeklemmt zwischen zwei Tischen. Ich fühle mich wie so eine Walnuss in so einer Zange, die jede Sekunde beknackt einfach. Ich bin wirklich, du hast wieder auf deiner Raumseite noch schönen Freiraum gemacht. Ich bin wirklich an beide Taillenseiten, ich bin wirklich festgeklammert. Deine Nieren aber schon seit 20 Minuten nicht mehr. Ich bin wirklich zwischen zwei Tischen komplett eingeklemmt, einfach wie auf so einer Schiene, als wäre ich so eine Monorail, die einfach sich nur noch vorne und hinten bewegen kann, aber rechts, links gar nicht. Ich finde auch wirklich, vielleicht müssen wir mal an dieser Raumsituation was machen, aber ich bin auch einfach zu faul. Mein Problem ist auch, ich wurde jetzt angerufen vor, das ist auch schon drei Monate her, von meinem Steuerberater. Oh, oh, oh. Außerdem nichts, ich dachte, oh Gott, was ist das von mir los? Oh, schlecht. Nichts Schlimmes, beruhigen Sie sich, Herr Tietze.
Wir wollten nur sagen, dass Sie bitte drei Ordner von sich abholen können. Da habe ich wohl, die legen einen Ordner dann für einen an, mit allen Belegen und Kram, sind auch Freiberuflige und so, und kommen viel rein, Jahressteuer, Shit und so, und dann lagern die die bei sich. Und für mich war das irgendwie so ein Eye-Opening-Call, weil ich dachte, ihr habt von jedem Menschen sehr, sehr viele Ordner bei euch. Wahnsinn. Und jetzt muss ich die zu mir nehmen, aber der Stellberater hat den Fehler gemacht, der gesagt hat, ja, beeilt mich. Oh nein, das darf man nicht sagen. Nein, und es ist jetzt... Oh nein, alles muss eilen. Oh mein Gott, ich habe mich noch nie so beruhigt. Und ich werde das jetzt nicht machen. Weil das heißt für mich jetzt, es eilt ja wirklich gar nicht. In einem Jahr hole ich die vielleicht ab, wenn ich dazu komme. Wenn ich Langeweile habe, hole ich die ab. Wenn ich mal in der Nähe bin. Wenn ich mal in der Nähe bin, bin ich nicht. Bis dahin legen Sie es in Altpapier und ich hole das von da dann ab. Legen Sie es oben auf dem Altpapier drauf. Schmeissen Sie es einfach weg. Aber gut, das war auf sich selber zu übertragen, zu sagen, ich darf niemals jemandem sagen, weil es eilt nicht. Weil dann kommt natürlich nichts. Ganz unklever, mit Menschen so zu reden. Auf gar keinen Fall. Menschen vertagen, Menschen lieben es zu vertagen. Es ist immer alles super notwendig. Ich mache morgen eh einen Apparillo-Tag. Ich habe mir vorgenommen, morgen wird telefoniert. Morgen wird der Apparat in die Hand genommen, die Wellscheibe wird rotieren und morgen mache ich einen Telefontag und ich habe keinen Bock drauf. Morgen wird ein harter Tag. Wir waren kurz davor, morgen aufzunehmen und zwar in einem ganz, ganz empfindlichen Zeitraum. Prekär. Ganz prekär. Wir hätten nämlich, wenn wir dich heute aufgenommen, hätten morgen aufgenommen. Und zwar direkt nach dem Friseurtermin. So. Friseurtermin und ich fahre direkt zur Aufnahme. Und ich glaube, wenn man mal mein Selbstbewusstsein in einem Grafen anzeigt und man sich fragt, was sind eigentlich die Punkte, wo das ganz unten ist. Ach, das sind immer Friseurtermine. Nein. Und dann dauert es immer so ein paar Tage, bis sich es wieder aufbaut. Und ich glaube, direkt nach dem Friseurtermin könnte mich ein auch nur halb zweischneidiges Kompliment einfach umhauen. Einfach so irgendwie, ach krass, du bist ja in echt viel fetter als im Fernsehen oder du siehst schlankerer aus in echt als im Fernsehen. Das ist ja zweischneidiges. Und ich so einfach klapp einfach um und sag, ich war eh schon auf wenig Lebensenergie, hab nur noch fünf, so blinkt mein Selbstbewusstsein, blinkt schon so am oberen Bildschirmrand. Der ganze Bildschirm ist dann rot. Bip, bip, bip, bip, bip. Und einer kommt so, ach bist du nicht, lass pausen und um. Wasted. Wasted. Genau so Zeitlupe, wie es so langsam zu Boden geht. Und du respawnst von einem Krankenhaus. Vor Friseur. Und da wäre ich echt verwundbar gewesen. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich dir hier entgegengetreten wäre, weil du erkennst mich normalerweise als selbstbewussten, nahezu schon fast überheblichen Charakter. Und morgen, da wäre ich wirklich am Boden gewesen. Schade jetzt eigentlich, das ärgert mich jetzt sehr. Und morgen, deswegen dachte ich mir, morgen bin ich eh verschämt, mache ich morgen Apparello-Tag. Aber dann haben wir die gleiche Friseurwoche gewählt. Ich habe diese Woche auch wieder einen Friseurtermin. Bin schon ganz aufgeregt. Wollen wir nicht auch mal zusammen zum Friseur? Auf gar keinen Fall. Nee, ich bin sehr, sehr glücklich gerade bei meiner Friseurin. Die hört den Podcast, she gets me. Die weiss, die kennt mich, die weiss, was mich stört, die weiss, was ich mag, die weiss, worüber ich reden will. Es ist entspannt. Mittlerweile ist, das Ding ist ja, wir sind ja beides eher sozial faule Wesen, so ein bisschen. Und ich glaube, manchmal muss man so an die richtigen Leute geraten oder einfach so ein bisschen sich aufraffen, um sie sozusagen wieder neue Comfortzone aufzubauen. Und ich behaupte, wenn du nach dem Friseur nicht gut drauf bist, hast du es noch nicht geschafft, quasi deine Comfortzone zu erweitern und quasi in deine Bubble auch noch diesen Friseurgang mit einzubeziehen. Ja, das stimmt. Das braucht ein Ja bei mir. Vor allem ist es dann auch immer so ein bisschen mit so einem, ah, soll ich noch was reintun? Nein, ach wirklich nicht, nein, so, weil ich denke mir schon, der Friseur denkt sich, wir alle stehen vor dem Haarschnitt und denken, es sieht scheiße aus. Kein Haarschnitt. Was ich mir immer denke, ich würde gerne zum Friseur gehen und sagen, ich würde gerne so aussehen wie ein Monat nach dem Friseurbesuch. Ja. Also wo sich das eingewachsen hat, wo es nicht mehr bescheuert aussieht. Aber ich glaube, das darf man nicht. Das sind so die ungeschriebenen Regeln. Ich finde dich gar nicht bescheuert nach dem Friseur. Das darf man nicht sagen. Ich finde dich viel, viel, viel hübscher nach dem Friseur. Ja, das ist nett, aber man fühlt sich ja selber einfach schwach und schutzlos vielleicht. Das ist auch ein menschlicher Instinkt, so wie wenn du so einen Hund die Haare scherst, der wird sich ja auch erst mal verwundbar und kalt fühlen oder so ein Schaf. Ja, so ein Schaf, wollte ich gerade sagen, aber du hast auch viele Haare, ich habe auf dem Kopf ja eher immer eine Kurzhaarfrisur. Du hast eher auf der Brust, einfach im Oberkörper. Ja, da habe ich die Wolle. Aber so auf den Haaren, auf dem Kopf habe ich ja quasi eine Kurzhaarfrisur und ich glaube, wenn man Kurzhaarfrisur Menschen Haare schneidet, dann sind die weniger empfindlich, weil die sich davor schon ausgeliefert geführt haben. Ja, ja, das stimmt. Und du hast ja quasi jetzt so ein schulterlanges dichtes Haar, welliges frohlockendes Haar zur Schulter. Ich glaube, das würde mich natürlich auch ein bisschen stören, glaube ich. Ich überlege mir auch immer so ein bisschen, wie weit man gehen kann beim Friseur. Weil kann ich jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, ich hätte gerne die Spitzen blondiert und dann abgeschnitten. Also erst die Spitzen zu blondieren und dann einfach nochmal abschneiden lassen. Sagt der Friseur dann, sag mal, nee warum, was soll das? Wem ist das doch scheißegal? Wirklich? Du zahlst doch die Haare. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob, nein, ich glaube, man hat auch einen Berufsethos, dass man so was nicht machen kann, dass man nicht einfach sagen kann, oder erst mal, nee, machen Sie mir jetzt locken und dann glätten. Irgendwie sowas. Einfach sagen so, ah nee, doch locken. Genau. Aber du buchst es schon so, locken, glätten, locken. Und er sagt, wir können das abkürzeln. Nee, nee, ich würde gerne, ich habe bezahlt, ich würde gerne die komplette Palette machen. Frage, bist du, wie kurz davor bist du sowas zu machen wie Locken, richtige Locken. Was heißt denn richtige Locken?
Nicht so deine kleinen Mini-Wellen, die du hast.
Nee, wenn, dann würde ich eher glätten lassen. Oder halt nochmal
komplett andere Haarfarbe. Ja, genau. Wie kurz bist du
vor
anderer Haarfarbe? Blond? Null.
Null Prozent. Ich sehe
meine Haarfarbenkarten
null. Leere Hand.
Tattoo? Eher. Eher Tattoo oder eher blondiert? Eher Tattoo als blondiert. Du weißt, dass blondiert nach vier Wochen raus ist. Ich würde sagen, blondieren Sie mir nur die Spitzen, dann gehe ich zu einem anderen Friseur und sage, bitte schneiden Sie genau nur die blonden Stähne raus. So ein offensichtlicher Fehlerkorrektur. Es wirkt wie so eine Schablone. Es wirkt wie so eine Schablone für den Haarschnitt. Wie so eine Test, so eine Puppe, die man jetzt dann so als Friseurlehrling abschneidet, wo man dann sagt, wo drauf steht dann so, wenn sie die Blonden, halten sie sich an den Blonden Strähnen. Genau, ja, so zur Übung. Ach so, wissen Sie was, da hole ich den Lehrling, der kann das gut machen. gut machen. Die Hälfte der Haare sind so lila gefärbt und du gehst zum Frisur und sagst, bitte schneiden Sie nur die lila den Haaren ab. Lila weg. Also offensichtlich, da hat irgendwas nicht so funktioniert, wie man sich dachte. Ja. Nee, auf jeden Fall, wenn dann eher Tattoo, aber halt dann so Augenbrauen-Tattoo, glaube ich. Augenbrauen-Bartattoo. Ja, das finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Doch, ich finde es sehr schlecht. Oder seid so die Koteletten einfach mal Tattoo, aber halt dann so Augenbrauen-Tattoo, glaube ich. Augenbrauen-Bart-Tattoo? Ja, das finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Doch, ich finde es sehr schlecht. Oder es halt so die Koteletten einfach mal Tattoo, dass du einfach sagst, ich kann mir das wegrasieren und bin da einfach safe. Weil damit du immer noch dichte Koteletten hast. Nee, aber wo würdest du ein Tattoo dir hinpflanzen, wenn du müsstest? Nee, ich würde wirklich so, ich würde mir wahrscheinlich Okay, wir bleiben beim Gesichtsquatsch. Okay. Ich würde so meinen Bart abrasieren, aber die Konturen wie bei so einer Comicfigur einfach so nachtritt. Wieder diese Schablone. Homer Simpson. Das heißt, wenn jemand kommt, ein Lehrling, ein Bartlehrling, wisst er genau, wo die Grenzen seines Barts sind. Ja, und dann würde ich mir das jeden Morgen so mit brauner Farbe ausmalen, so diesen Bereich einfach. Damit ich aussehe wie Homer Simpson. Aber nicht über die Linie. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, Schablon, Mann, dass alle Service-Menschen um dich herum immer sehr, sehr klar wissen, was sie so tun haben. Wirklich so alles ganz klar definiert, das ist wichtig für mich, das ist ganz klar. Da ist Bart, der hört auf, das ist genau die Grenze, wo er aufhört, und diese blonden Haare, die können alle weg. Ja, finde ich alles nicht so schlecht. Nee, Tattoo habe ich noch nicht lange nachgedacht, aber wenn dann halt wirklich so schönes Knöcheltattoo einfach. Knöchel, ne? So ein Halbmond oder sowas. Ach so, ich dachte jetzt die Umrisse des Knöchels, also da wo der Knöchel aufhört, so ein Kreis drum. Ja. Oder halt einfach so die Augen, über den Augenbrauen so einfach so Linien zur Mitte, so dass man immer böse guckt. Solche Tattoos fände ich gut einfach, so dass man immer so böse guckt. Ein bisschen. Ja, ja. Das wäre toll, weil ich vielleicht auch ernster genommen werde. Lieblingsmoment von Fluchtau-Kalibik 2, wo Jack Sparrow auf den Augen Augen gemalt hat. Toll. Stark. Oh, aber das wäre ein Make ein Make-up besuch, der hätte mich wahnsinnig gemacht, auf den Augen, Augen, Liedern Augen gemalt zu bekommen. Wirklich, tatsächlich, es ist vielleicht, habt ihr es gesehen, neuer Film in den Kinos? Ja, The French Dispatch. Geht wieder los? Nee, Contra, deutscher Film. Also, Christoph Marie Herbst und Nila Farouk, die vielleicht viele von euch als euch als Darum noch kennen, YouTuberin. Und immer wenn ich an diesem Kinoplakat vorbeikomme, es läuft mir eiskalt über den Rücken. Es läuft mir eiskalt über den Rücken, weil ich habe ein Trauma mit Darum, mit Nila Farouk, ich habe einfach ein Trauma, weil ich habe einmal eine ihrer Videos geschaut, so ein Vlog-Video, wo sie so erzählt und einfach so in die Kamera guckt und erzählt und sowas. Und mitten während sie erzählt, einfach so völlig im Wort, weil sie hat dann so lange Fingernägel, so verlängerte Fingernägel, und mitten im Satz, einfach völlig selbstverständlich, kommt ihr Finger ins Bild und sie kratzt sich am Augapfel. Nein! Mit den langen Fingernägeln. Nicht am Lied, nicht am Augen. Das ist für mich sogar schon schlimm. Nicht am Augen, Lied, nein, nein, sondern seitlich am Augapfel. Warum sollte man den jucken? Bin wirklich fast ohmächtig geworden. Warum sollte man den kratzen? Was? Der juckt doch nicht. Und ich habe in die Kommentare geguckt und niemand hat es erwähnt. Und ich dachte mir, es ist einfach... Also sie ist wahrscheinlich eine fantastische Schauspielerin, aber ich kann mir diesen Film nicht angucken. Weil immer wenn ich sie Close-up sehe, denke ich, jede Sekunde, jede Sekunde kommt sie und ich weiß nicht, was da los ist. Frau Baumann, da spürt man doch nichts. Warum hast du das Bedürfnis, den Augapfel zu kratzen? Er juckt ja nicht. Ja, vielleicht nicht, vielleicht bei ihr schon, ich weiß es nicht. Nein, ne. Oh, ganz, ganz schrecklich. Deswegen tut es mir leid, ich würde gerne, vielleicht kaufe ich ein Ticket, ohne mir den Film anzuschauen. Als Geste, als gute Geste. Nee, schau schön The French Dispatch, schau Dune. Ja, ich habe jetzt Dune gesehen, ey, wirklich, es ist manchmal wirklich eine Katastrophe, wenn man versucht, Dune noch so in den letzten zwei Wochen zu sehen, in denen der Film läuft, nur noch in den schäbigsten Kinos, nur noch in drei Kinos oder so, alle davon voll gebucht und ich musste in fünfzig Minuten mit dem Auto fahren in ein Kino, in dem es nicht mal so Kinobänke gab, so Kinoreihen, sondern einzelne Stühle in dem Saal. Warum Leinwand vorne? Dune ist der größte Blockbuster der letzten Jahre, der läuft überall. Nein, eben nicht mehr. Und es läuft nur noch ein paar Kinos und die sind alle voll. Und ich war in einem Kino, in dem einzelne, wie so Bürostühle, Bürostühle ohne Rollen. So standen die einfach in diesem Raum. Ich dachte mir, wenn in diesem Kino dieser Film mich verzaubern kann, dann ist er wirklich gut. Und ich sag mal, Denis Villeneuve, du hast es geschafft. Hast du es geschafft? Selbst in dem Kino, nicht mal in OV, ich musste es in Deutsch anschauen, weil es gab keine OV-Vorstellung. Jetzt machst du dich einfach nur lächerlich. Nein, es ist wirklich so. Aber wo warst du denn? Warst du denn in der Nähe von Köln? Ich musste ihn in Hamburg anschauen. Ja, okay. Glaub ich dir nicht. Es gab nichts anderes. Sie sind noch grösser als Köln. Es gab nichts anderes. Und es ist vor allem, ich bin ja nicht oft in Kinos, wie völlig selbstverständlich für Leute, das ist die deutsche Version zu schauen, dass sie das nicht mehr hinschreiben, Vorstellung in Deutsch oder Sprache Deutsch, sondern es wird einfach selbstverständlich davon ausgegangen, dass es deutsch ist und nach UV muss man explizit suchen. Ja, war furchtbar, aber trotzdem, das ist für mich ein gutes Zeichen, dass wenn selbst in einem schäbigen Kino, also was heißt schäbiges, kleines Kino? Büro, es war ein Konferenzraum, es war ein Konferenzraum, wo Jeff mal eben den Beamer angemacht hat. Es war ein Konferenzraum mit dem Fernseher. Also da, selbst wenn da der Film nicht verzaubern kann, aber anstrengender Film. Ich habe versucht, mir alle Namen zu merken und hatte wirklich so ein, ich packe meinen Koffer und nehme mit. Timothy Scherr. Harkonnen, Fremen, Asterides, wirklich so Versuch, alle mir Namen zu merken, weil der Film ist ja 80 Prozent Worldbuilding irgendwie. Ja. Aber auch da. Name-pping. Es ist ein Name-Dropping. Ich finde es immer toll, also da achte ich immer drauf, wie in so Fantasy-Science-Fiction-Welten, und ich glaube, das muss so sein, dass es auch Elemente gibt, die normal sind. Beispiel, die Hauptfigur, unser guter alter Timothy Chalamet oder Timothée. Nee, aber sag mal den Namen, wie ist er denn? Paul. Das ist einfach Paul. Das war nämlich mein Kritikpunkt ganz am Anfang vor, bevor die Jungen überhaupt im Kino lief oder im Konferenzraum, war nämlich mein Kritikpunkt, ah, castet doch nicht bei so geilen Franchises wieder die alten Nasen, weil niemand ist bereit. Timothy ist doch nicht alt! Natürlich ist es, es gibt doch nur fünf Leute, die... Nichts gegen Timothy, Alter. Du sagst nichts gegen Timothy Schallermey, okay? Das ist immer die gleichen. Du wünschst es, es wäre dann Bay. Aber der ist von je, ja klar, ich liebe den ja auch. Bullshit, als alle in 100 Filmen, das ist ein Newcomer, der hat noch viel vor sich. Ja, aber es ist immer der gleiche, es ist in allen Filmen der gleiche. Was? Können wir nicht mal neue Leute casten? Du bist völlig vom Weg. Können wir nicht mal neue Leute haben? Nein, gerade der ist ja neu, was das angeht, als Hauptrolle in dem grossen Franchise mit mehreren Teilen. Es gibt doch mehr Leute als ihn und Tom Holland. Wenn der jetzt irgendwie, wenn der jetzt, äh, Matt Damon mitgespielt hätte, dann wäre ich bei dir. Nein. Aber Timothée Chalamet. Aber jetzt mal ganz kurz, es gibt doch wirklich nur ... Die sind Rollen. Bullshit. Kleiner, junger, gut aussehender Leading Man. Nein. Hast du nur Timothée Chalamet und Tom Holland. Und es geht mir auf die Nerven. Es sind immer nur die beiden. Nicht in einem grossen, mehrteiligen Sci-Fi-Blockbuster. Der spielt toll. Ich finde ihn toll, wegen dem wir ins Kino. Ich finde auch Zendaya super. Aber auch da ... Ja, die schaut in die Ferne. Die ist auch überall. Lustigerweise spielt sie auch mit Tom Holland dann im Spider-Man. Ja, jetzt wird's albern, jetzt wird's albern. Und dann bei den alten Nasen gehst du auch wieder auf die gleichen. Gehst du auf Scar's Guard, gehst du auf Oscar Isaac. Langsam reicht es mir mit den ganzen alten Namen, die wir schon alle kennen. Macht's doch mal wie George Lucas damals bei Fucking Star Wars und castes A Bunch of New Shit. Aber was ist denn mit den ganzen Schauspielern, die man noch nicht kennt in dem Film? Die, die ja gar nicht aufgefallen sind. Das ist es nämlich. Du redest ja nicht über die, die neu sind, die du gar nicht kennst. Über das alles die Hauptcharaktere sind. Naja, nicht alle. Was ist mit dem Kleinen, der einmal an der Seite ist? Ja, gegen Hab ich das nicht gekannt. Ja, aber ich wollte nur sagen, die Hauptfigur in diesen ganzen mit irgendwie Harkonnen, Fremen, Asteroides, mit diesen ganzen Sci-Fi-Namen, heißt Paul. Die Hauptfigur heißt Paul. Und seine Mutter heißt Jennifer. Also in dieser ganzen Sci-Fi-Welt, wo alle coole Namen haben, die Hauptfiguren Paul und Jennifer. Und ich denke, das muss so sein. Weil in allen, also zum Beispiel auch bei Herr der Ringe. Oder Onkel Owen und Luke.
Onkel Owen, ja, Owen und Luke.
Weil auch bei Herr der Ringe zum Beispiel, wo du Figuren
heisst, die heisst irgendwie Gombli, Gimbli,
Gralezzo, Gawatzki,
Gorbolodo, es gibt auch einfach Sam.
Einer muss
normalen Namen heißen.
Ja, Sam.
Aber selbst bei den Hobbits,
du hast Frodo, Peco, Letto, du hast Pepecolini, du hast verschiedene Leute.
Pepecolini, Ramazzotti, das alle. Aber du hast halt auch einfach Sam. Und das ist der einzige Normale in der gesamten Geschichte. Niemand hat sonst einen normalen Namen, außer Sam. Und den brauchst du, du brauchst einen normalen Namen. Warum? Das muss so sein. Punkt habe ich nicht verstanden, warum?
Ich versuche es ja abzuleiten davon.
Ja, ja, du reverse-engineerst.
Oder zum Beispiel bei Harry Potter, Harry.
Oder auch sein Vater James. Er kommt aus einer ganz normalen Welt und ist ja wichtig, dass er der Normal-Dude aus der ... Nein. Es ist nicht wichtig, dass er normal ist. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Seine Zauberer-Eltern haben ihm den Namen gegeben. Harry Potter ist kein Muggel-Name, okay? Okay, haben wir uns verstanden. Ja, aber das ist jetzt anders als bei den anderen Sachen. Das ist ja eine Welt, die in der echten Welt, auf die echte Welt beruht. Es gibt ja sozusagen die Erde im Kanon. Der ist ja aufgewachsen in London, der ist ja dazu schuldig gegangen. Ja, aber auch da haben die verrückte Zauberer Namen, Hagrid und Severus und sowas. Das sind ja auch keine normalen Vornamen. Da meine ich auch so, du brauchst einfach James, der könnte ja auch irgendwie Hobbolob heißen oder irgendwie sowas, oder Kringaletz oder irgendwie sowas, so weirde Voldemort-mässig Sachen, obwohl der ist einfach auch Tom, ne? Voldemort ist auch noch Tom. Tommy. Tomo! Ja, stimmt schon. Tom Riddle, auch kein böser Name. Der Riddle, The Riddler. Ja, ich glaube, es muss so sein, also falls ihr an einem Fantasy-Abenteuer arbeitet, macht nicht den Fehler und gebt allen Sachen kreative, weirde Namen, sondern habt auch mal Mut, die Schwester vom Hauptcharakter, einfach Katrin. Katamaran. Wenn die Hauptfigur Katamaran heißt, auch die Schwester Alfa Katrin zu nennen, das ist erlaubt. Das ist erlaubt und ich glaube, es ist sogar gut. Ja, ich habe ja mal, ich habe auch mal angefangen, Sci-Fi-Film zu schreiben. Ja, ich auch. Haben wir hier sogar vorgelesen, meine Sci-Fi-Geschichte, falls du dich erinnerst. Darf ich nochmal fragen, von wann die war? Da war ich ziemlich jung. Das glaube ich nämlich nicht. Irgendwie sowas, 16, 17, maximal 18. Es wird immer später auch, aber okay. Ich frage dich das in ein paar Jahren nochmal und dann sagst du, ja, das war kurz davor. Ich wollte eigentlich nur mal wissen, wie das dir gefällt. Ich habe immer Probleme damit gehabt am Anfang, einfach selbstbewusst es mal durchzuziehen, diese verrückte Welt, die man da irgendwie im Kopf hat so ein bisschen, aus Papier zu bringen, weil es immer sich albern durchliest.
Also es klingt immer, weiß ich nicht, man verlangt sehr viel von den Leuten, die das lesen. Und dann habe ich mir deswegen mal Josh Lucas' Star Wars in New Hope damals mal das Drehbuch, mit dem sie angefangen haben zu drehen, durchgelesen und so. Und das liest sich auch so. Das sind einfach Leute, die einfach komplett all in gehen mit ihren Charakteren und mit dem Worldbuilding. Und ich dachte auch so, wie genau beschreibt er denn jetzt die Figuren, diese weirden Aliens, die da in der Kantine zum Beispiel sind und so. Und er redet eigentlich immer von Alienwesen und so was. Also der spricht jetzt auch nicht, sagt auch nicht das blaue Wesen mit den langen, das Twi'lek mit den langen Gesichtslappen. So, das kommt dann auch nicht. Also das ist ja dann auch was, was man an anderen Departments überlässt. Also deine Aufgabe als Drehbuchautor ist ja erstmal, nur eine Geschichte zu erzählen, noch nicht einen Film. Und das fand ich schon interessant. Aber ja, in Gericht habe ich es trotzdem nicht und habe es dann auch abgebaut.
Ich bin gespannt. Also wir arbeiten ja noch intensiv an unserer Erotik-Geschichte, was tatsächlich schwerer ist, als man denkt, da auch eine Geschichte mit einzubauen irgendwie.
Und das irgendwie, also klar, plötzlich habe ich Respekt vor Pornoautoren.
Wirklich, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, weil man muss ja irgendwo anfangen. Es muss ja irgendwie Interior, Morgans, Frau in Küche, da muss ja was losgehen. Ja. Das ist gar nicht so leicht. Nö, wobei man weiß bei Pornos Gott sei Dank schon oft, wie es endet. Also das ist schon was, was jetzt, finde ich, so Serienautoren voraus haben, dass man, also man weiß, worauf es hinausläuft. Ja, das stimmt schon, ja. Wir haben nämlich von euch wissen wollen, was sind tolle, könnt ihr uns gute Elfchen schreiben, erotische Elfchen. Ja. Wir haben vor einigen Wochen die Kunstform des Elfchens kennen und lieben gelernt. Ich liebe es immer noch. Elfwörter? Florian hat gerade gesagt, er hat sich ein bisschen überfressen an Elfchen. Mein Problem war, dass ich halt vor, bevor du mich an diese Kunstform herangeführt hast, ich noch kein einziges Elfchen in meinem ganzen Leben gelesen habe. Und jetzt in den letzten zwei Wochen bestimmt hundert Elfchen von euch, vielen, vielen Dank für die ganze kreative Energie, die da reingeflossen ist, aber irgendwann ist es auch gut. Aber ganz ehrlich, ich liebe diese Kunstform, ich muss immer lachen, was auch ein bisschen in der Natur der Sache liegt, ohne euch jetzt zunahe zu treten, so toll eure Elfchen auch sind, aber diese Kunstform an sich ist einfach auch schon lustig. Es ist aber auch eine Elfform, weil du hast ja ein Wort, zwei Wort, drei Wort, vier Wort, ein Wort. Also du hast so einen Aufbau. Es ist selbst schon lustig, wenn man das sagt. Ja, du hast so eine Sprungsschanze, so einen Aufbau und dann radikales Abstürzen auf ein Wort. Ein Wort, zwei Wort, drei Wort, vier Wort, ein Wort. Ja, also du, du. Es ist eine Pointenstruktur, das letzte Wort ist notwendigerweise eine Pointe. Das ist immer lustig auch, weil es halt so, weil es halt niemals an die Erwartungen des davor hingegen, die Zeile, es ist ein bisschen schwer vorzutragen, weil du hast halt, diese Zeilenstruktur ist auch wichtig.
Und ihr versteht hoffentlich, dass wir auch nicht auf alle eure Elfchen eingehen können. Wir hoffen, ihr hattet Spaß beim Schreiben. Aber Stefan hat die Gewinner gekürt, die besten Elfchen. Nee, erstmal, also wir haben wieder eine sehr schwierige, verzweigte Aufgabe gestellt, Erotik-Elfchen, ja, müsste aber auch keine Erotik-Elfchen sein, deswegen haben wir auch andere normale Elfchen bekommen, es kommen auch noch aus den Wochen davor, von den Hörern, die ein bisschen zu langsam sind, von denen kommen auch noch Elfchen, das heißt, wir kriegen jetzt einfach Elfchen. Das heißt, ich trage jetzt einfach Elfchen vor, manche davon sind vielleicht ein bisschen schlüpfrig. So, Jan, ab wann könnt ihr feststellen, ob es sich um ein Erotik-Elfchen oder um ein Neutral-Elfchen handelt? Nach wie vielen Wörtern? Das ist mal die Herausforderung für die fortgeschrittenen Elfchen-Kondisseure von euch da draußen. Jan schreibt, hier mein Elfchen, Anschläge, schwarz-weiss, mit kurzen Pausen, seit Jahren ohrenbetäubender Lärm, Klavierspiel.
Ich glaube, hier hat Jan versucht, so ein bisschen die Beziehung zu seinen Nachbarn zu verarbeiten, fand ich gut. Jetzt kommt ein erotisches Älfchen von Jule. Vorschlag Herzen klopfen, Buch wird aufgeschlagen. Körper verbiegen sich unnatürlich. Zerrung. Das finde ich sehr gut. Sehr schön, ja. Buch wird aufgeschlagen. Das habe ich nicht verstanden. Aber du brauchst immer so, das nennt man den Nabel des Elfchens, das, was nicht verstanden werden kann, der blinde Fleck, der das Elfchen aber erdet. Du meinst, das ist jetzt der Geruch, was Jennifer Launitz beschrieben hat, dieser unangenehme Geruch, der den Geruch jetzt richtig geil macht. Ich finde das sehr lustig, Vorschlag, Herzen klopfen, Buch wird aufgeschlagen, Körper verbiegen sich und natürlich Zerrung. Mochte ich sehr. Sönke Tetzla schreibt, und das klingt wie eine Parodie auf meinen Namen, ein Elfchen, ich habe ein Elfchen zum Thema, nein, das möchte ich noch nicht verraten. Gürkchen, gekühlt, ruhend, Gläschen als Zuhause, grünes Glück im Essigmantel, Genuss. Schön, schön. Finde ich auch schön. Hat jetzt nicht so diesen Überraschungscharakter, aber auf jeden Fall ein interessantes Blödsinn. Dafür ist es ein Alliterations-Elfchen, alle Zeilen fangen mit G an. Und Gläschen als Zuhause finde ich auch süsseste, was jemals ein Mensch geschrieben hat. Sehr, sehr süsser Gläschen. Kev, wahrscheinlich für Kevin, schreibt.
Drache, ist rot, säuselt im Wind, das Leben fliegt vorbei, tot.
Mit D oder mit T am Ende?
D.
Und Clary, die Girls schreiben die heftigen Sex-Elfchen. Deswegen hat Clary noch ein tolles Elfchen geschrieben. Feucht. Titten hängen. Harte, steife Glieder. Komme ins dunkle Loch. Tropfsteinhülle. Ach so, euer Gregor und eure Clarissa. Oh, okay, da wurde sogar zusammengegangen. Also da wurde sogar zusammengegangen. Da wurde zusammengegangen, weil er Doppel-Co-Autoren. Ja, das waren für diese Woche die Elfchen von euch. Wow, also, puh, mir ist echt ein bisschen warm geworden. Puh, hart, hart, hart, hart, hart. Wie kommt man auf sowas? Also, falls ihr Schwierigkeiten habt beim Dirty Talk, ist ja für manche eine Herausforderung,
versucht einfach mal während des Sex die Elfchenform
anzuwenden, vielleicht klappt das ja.
Dirty Talk, finde ich, ist eine
Kunst, die ich noch nicht durchstiegen habe.
Es ist schwierig. Wo ich gar keinen
Bezug zu habe und ich
bin der geschlechteste Dirty Talker auf
der ganzen, ganzen weiten Welt.
Auch nicht mal Gags oder so?
Ne, Gags, ja doch, Gags schon. Aber das ist ja das Gegentechteste Dirty Talker auf der ganzen, ganzen weiten Welt. Auch nicht mal Gags oder so? Nee, Gags, ja doch, Gags schon. Aber das ist das Gegenteil von Dirty Talk. Gag ist das absolute Gegenteil. Das ist Clean Talk. The cleanest talk. Das kann ich gut. Aber Dirty, nee, bei mir ist Clean, Clean Talk. Ist wahrscheinlich auch so, könnte ich mir zumindest bei dir vorstellen, dass sowas wie Sexting oder so eher anspruchsvoll ist, weil du natürlich versuchst, gute Sachen zu schreiben und dich vielleicht nicht so ganz fallen lassen kannst in die Texterotik. Das stimmt. Ich sag mal, Emojis helfen. Vor allem die Auberginen.
Auberginen helfen.
Sie trägt eine Menge Gewicht.
Auberginen und Wassertropfen tragen dazu bei, loslassen zu können. Das stimmt eigentlich, die Emojis haben Sexting revolutioniert. Dennoch, jetzt wo ich das gesagt habe, muss ich auch sagen, dass ich schon versuche, mit Relativsetzen, Nebensätzen zu arbeiten, ein bisschen anschaulicher zu sein, mein eh schon eher Satzzeichen-driven, richtige Semantik, Schriftdeutsch steht mir im Weg. Deine Erotik ist sehr satzzeichenlastig, muss man wirklich mal sagen. Was dein eigener Stil ist, was zu dir passt und es hat was Individuelles, was ja auch reizvoll ist. Aber es ist schon sehr grammatisch, muss man insgesamt schon sagen. Man muss auch da ein paar Mal lesen den Satz, um den zu verstehen, was der Erotik vielleicht ein bisschen im Weg steht. Ja, nein, also du verwendest den Plusquam perfekt wie kein zweiter als erotisches Stimulanzmittel. Werden gefickt, haben, ich liebe auch Foto 2. Das machst du gut, aber du lässt manchmal den deutschen LK raushängen, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, aber auch das kann sexy sein. Germanistische Studie im Deutschen LK wird raushängen gelassen haben worden. Seine. Sehr schön, ja. Ich bin gespannt, wir bleiben dran, aber auch hier, wir haben gesagt, es eilt nicht und dementsprechend sehe ich es noch nicht. Elfchen eilt nie. Vielleicht bringen wir auch mal ein Band raus. Ich glaube, das ist so wirklich was, wo Verleger wirklich fluchtartig den Raum verlassen. Man sagt so, wissen Sie, ich würde gerne mein Buch rausbringen. Ah, wirklich so witzige Anekdoten aus dem Alltag, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Nee, so gesammelte Elfchen. Oh, vielleicht so auf jeder Seite ein Elfchen und gegenüber noch ein Bild, das dazu passt. Ja, ich muss, ich glaube, ich habe im Haltverbot geparkt. Ich muss, Entschuldigung, ich komme gleich wieder. Wir zeigen hier heute Abend noch Dune. Es wäre schön, wenn Sie einfach den Raum in der Konferenz verlassen können. Wir machen heute Abend noch hier ein Screening. Ja, das stimmt schon,, das hätte ich mal, weil Buch und so, keine Ahnung, kann ich mich nicht, ich bringe nicht das Selbstvertrauen auf, ein Buch zu schreiben. Ich hätte mal aber Bock, nach Japan zu reisen, drei Monate, wollte ich immer schon mal machen, da bin ich dann, da müssen wir auch gucken, wie wir dann aufnehmen. Anderes Problem müsst ihr euch nicht mit beschäftigen, liebe Hörer, das ist unser Ding,
das müssen wir dann mal logistisch
klären, wie wir das überhaupt machen. Genau, bitte schreibt dazu
nichts, keine Vorschläge, Orga-Tools,
Zeitzonen, Link. Wollte ich jetzt eigentlich
gar nicht erwähnen. Wie gesagt, das ist,
warum werden wir uns kümmern, wenn die
Probleme entstehen. Genau, wenn die entstehen,
werden wir uns wieder auseinandersetzen, lösen
und vorbeiziehen lassen.
Aber da wollte ich dann gerne,
ich wollte von den Norden
in den Süden reisen und gerne
... Und werden wir uns wieder auseinandersetzen, lösen und vorbeiziehen lassen. Aber da wollte ich dann gerne, ich wollte von den Norden in den Süden reisen und gerne über jeden Zwischenstopp, den ich mache, diese ganzen 50 Zwischenstopps ein Haiku schreiben. Okay. Und das wollte ich dann gerne veröffentlichen. Ja? In was Schönem, mit irgendeiner Illustratorin, mit Illustrator. Mit so einem Kunstleder-Einband irgendwie. Ein schöner Einband. Oder sowas, was zu Japan passt, irgendwie so ein Blüten, für sich Blüten einband. Mit einem Federn auf Blüten geschriebenes, tolles, sehr teures Buch. Aber auch dann so Kalligrafie-mäßig, das dann alles schön auch eingeschrieben. Ja genau, von so alten Kalligrafie-Meistern auf Pergamentrollen geschrieben, mit Tinte. Oder halt, du könntest sowas schreiben, so wie ich die Neunziger erlebt habe irgendwie und dann so pro Kapitel Tamagotchi und irgendwie Alf oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Das kommt gut an bei den Leuten, weil die können sich damit total gut identifizieren und sie sind ja eher so der crazy, verrückte Typ. Ich glaube, da können sie so ein paar witzige Anekdoten und nochmal einen ganz frischen Blick auf die 90er. Die 90er übrigens wirklich kann ich nicht mehr hören. Ich kann die 90er nicht mehr ertragen. Tut mir leid. Nee, kein Stranger Things. 90er ist auch nicht Stranger Things. Stranger Things ist... Kein Fresh Prince mehr? Nee, 90er mag ich nicht. Du hast abgeschlossen. Musik mag ich nicht. Du bist wieder voll in den Nullerjahren. Ich bin mal kurz ehrlich. 90er Jahre ist für mich ein Jahrzehnt, was sich stilistisch komplett verrannt hat. Sowohl mit Kleidung, sowohl mit Musik, sowohl mit Film, mit allem. Und damit will ich auch nicht erst mal nichts mehr zu tun haben. Was hast du gegen Matrix? Was hast du gegen Fight Club? Was hast du gegen Star Wars Episode I?
Gegen Jurassic Park?
Nee, komm, jetzt ist es albern. Jurassic Park war viel früher.
Na Gott.
Naja, ich weiss ja, es gibt ja Ausreisser.
Ich meine jetzt ja nur mal einmal.
Die 90er sind ja wirklich kein Jahrzehnt, was ich vermissen würde.
Wenn man aus deinem Gehirn ein Jahrzehnt löschen könnte, müsste, was wäre es? Schwierig. Die Nuller. Die Nuller? Die Nuller. Die machen's Jamba-Abo und die Abschlussklasse und all das. Das war eher so die Phase, die mich geprägt hat intensiv. Ja, aber dann wärst du ja vielleicht ein anderer Mensch, wenn du sie nicht kennen würdest. Ja, das stimmt auch wieder. Weiß ich nicht. Stefan, wir verabschieden uns, wünschen euch ein schönes Jahrzehnt und was sonst noch kommt? Das ist die letzte Folge und dann dachte ich mir, was ist das eine enttäuschende letzte Folge, das gewesen ist. Es kann sein, vielleicht wird die Erde vernichtet in ein paar Stunden. Ne, das kann aber wirklich sein. Wir wissen es nicht,
kann sein. Wir wünschen euch bis dahin noch ganz,
ganz viel Spaß, haut rein, habt noch einen schönen Abend
und eine schöne Woche. Habt eine schöne Woche,
macht's gut. Und wir heben ab.
Macht's gut, ciao.